-Guys, like I said earlier,
everyone's talking about
today's recall election
in California.
There are a lot of candidates
trying to replace
Governor Gavin Newsom,
so we wanted to break it all
down for you.
It's time for "Fast Stats."
Here we go.
-♪ Learn some fast stats,
fast stats ♪
-First, we have Larry Elder.
His job is
conservative radio host.
Party trick -- Eating
an entire apple in two bites.
Previous job --
Playing the principal
on a Nickelodeon show where
he gets slimed every episode.
[ Applause ]
Next, we have Rhonda Furin.
Job -- Self-employed.
Former job --
Background exerciser
in every '80s workout video.
Often mistaken for --
A woman on a "Dateline" episode
who definitely
killed her husband.
[ Applause ]
Next up, it's Kevin Faulconer.
Job --
Former mayor of San Diego.
Wants to know -- "What's gonna
get you in the driver's seat
of this 2005
Hyundai Elantra today?"
First thing he'll do
in the office --
Even out his spray tan.
[ Applause ]
Then we have Robert Newman.
Job -- Farmer.
Currently --
FaceTiming his grandchildren
too close to the camera.
Last seen --
as a signed head shot
on the wall
of an Italian restaurant.
[ Applause ]
And finally, it's David Moore.
Job -- Teacher.
Last person he upset --
His barber.
Catalogue model for --
Clip-on ties.
Campaign slogan --
"Don't call them comic books,
they're graphic novels."
This has been "Fast Stats,"
everybody.
Thank you very much.